Bloopers offer a peek into the filmmaking
process, humanizing Hollywood stars by showing
them flubbing their lines, goofing up, and
just generally having a good, silly time while
it's all captured for posterity.
Bloopers are especially fun when they're from
unexpected sources—such as serious actors
who win lots of awards for their dramatic
roles.
Here are some little-seen screw-ups and goof-offs
from some of the most respected dramatic performers
in Hollywood history.
Marlon Brando
Among the most acclaimed actors of all time,
Marlon Brando disappeared into his characters
in classic films like The Godfather and On
the Waterfront.
He lends just the right amount of gravitas
to the role of Superman's father in a cameo
appearance in the first Superman film in 1978.
But while Brando was once the very definition
of "serious actor," he didn't always take
himself all that seriously.
In one outtake from Superman, he transitions
from the scripted poem ...
"A tree whose branches wide and strong…"
… into a Stephen Foster song, cracking up
the crew ...
" … the Camptown ladies sing this song / Doo
dah / Doo dah … "
"Cut!"
Hugh Jackman
A versatile actor equally skilled to handle
costume dramas, action movies, and musicals,
Hugh Jackman is best known for the role of
Wolverine in the X-Men series, and brings
depth and nuance to a comic book character
that could be one-note.
But on the set of the 2004 monster-hunter
movie Van Helsing, he doesn't even have Wolverine's
adamantium claws to blame for a prop breaking
in his hands ...
"Hmmm.
Broke.
Good enough.
It's a low-budget movie!
I'm sorry!"
Bryan Cranston
As Walter White on Breaking Bad, Bryan Cranston
was the ominous "one who knocks"—and he
won four Emmys for his gripping portrayal.
That role involved a lot of difficult dialogue,
from long monologues to rattling off the names
of chemicals and scientific processes.
But it didn't prepare Cranston for one particularly
gnarly bit of dialogue in the 2012 remake
of Total Recall ...
"I want him alive for re — re-implantation."
BOOP
"I want him alive for re-inflan —" BOOP
"Re-implantation."
Naomi Watts
While she almost exclusively acts in really
intense dramas like 21 Grams and The Impossible,
Naomi Watts lightened her workload a little
with a major role in Peter Jackson's King
Kong remake in 2005.
The blooper reel for the movie reveals an
actress that has an almost pathological inclination
to swear when she flubs a line ...
"Is it — oh, for f---'s sake."
"The thing that I was afraid of is that you
would be one of those self-obsessed … f---wits."
Matt Damon
He's one of the finest actors of his generation,
and a beloved movie star to boot, but Matt
Damon, of course, is not really a genius scientist—he
just plays one in The Martian.
Most of Damon's scenes in the sci-fi film
are of him alone, stranded on Mars, carefully
devising ways that he can prolong his survival.
Math helps in that kind of situation, but
Damon amusingly had a hard time getting that
part right ...
"Oh Jesus."
"Let's clean that up and go again please."
Uma Thurman
As the stoic, revenge-obsessed Bride in Quentin
Tarantino's two-part Kill Bill epic, Uma Thurman
rarely got a chance to be funny.
Her character is generally about as hilarious
as a hole in the head…like the one Thurman
makes when she reaches into a fight opponent's
noggin and pulls out a bloody eyeball ...
"And … action!"
"Cut!"
"Oh, c'mon, let's do it again!"
J.K. Simmons
One of the most prolific and versatile character
actors in Hollywood, J.K. Simmons won an Oscar
for his role as a brutal drum instructor in
Whiplash… which was a far cry from his role
as a soft-spoken police chief on the TNT cop
drama The Closer… which is a far cry from
his role as the blustery newspaper editor
J. Jonah Jameson in the first Spider-Man trilogy.
He's got to deliver Jameson's lines strongly,
loudly, and at a rapid clip — in an outtake
from Spider-Man 3, Simmons gets at least two
out of three right ...
"Congratulations, son ... (unintelligible
gibberish).
"Congratulations, Brock, we'll use your shot
… (unintelligible gibberish)."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!